welcome to chess history world
championships
today we're going to talk about the
world championship match from 2010
between Topalov and anand fat the game
that I wanted to cover was already
covered by a V Friedman blessed his oily
hide to Hades anyway turns out we're
doing this lecture during the London
classic although you won't know that
because you're going to see this two
weeks later but thus far Anand in
classic the only players who have
decisive results are top 11 andand
and the other decisive results are
people who played against top 11 Anand
because the other games are all drawers
however top 11 Anand have three decisive
results each so they're keeping the
tournament interesting now the game that
I wanted to show Anand won with black in
the last game of the match to retain his
title although it's not clear the world
championship world champion ones I think
they both were and depending on your
point of view now this is one of the
earlier games that was won by Topalov
and it's actually in an opening high of
interest in normally I like to show
three or four games but since this game
was a 1 billion moves long I have to
just show this one there's a very funny
notes of this game by the the
commentator wrote Gouzenko I'll try to
ignore his comments if I can but one of
them was when Topalov played a novelty
about move 1718 rogas n KO was shocked
that a non head and analyzed this move
you know and I was thinking you're
supposed to analyze novelties to I move
17 it's high standards okay so they
played a Slav okay and they played the
regular slot which is very strange
that's a super duper top level they like
to play the semi Slav which some of them
also call this log but okay so II played
D takes e4 which is a move that I've
played many times and white plays a4 to
prevent black from playing b5
Bishop f5 is the most common move now
white usually plays Knight e5 or e3 I'm
guessing I faced III more in my praxis
in the Slav but top alot played 95 which
it's probably slightly more common at
the very top level and they're playing
two or three different ways here for
black and they sort of changed recently
then they change back so I always played
a six here but a lot of the super genes
play 9b d7 they play both now not at the
same time II 6 ok this is a move that
I've played f3 f3 is the main idea of 95
now for those of you who aren't familiar
with the position you might think well
white wants to take his pawn back well
he sort of does but more importantly
white wants to play F 3 and E 4 and have
a dominating Center and that's what he
did f3 and c5 now again black has two
moves here usually why did black have
couple of moves it almost any position
up until move 8 or 9 and I always play
Bishop to b4 which led to this crazy pea
sacrifice and now black wants to take on
c3 so Bishop to d2 Queen takes d4
threatening checkmate Knight takes Queen
takes check Bishop takes check and this
was actually popularized by Karpov in
the early 80s ladies mid 80s I think it
was an 88 against er gerson this line
was known but nobody played it then
Karpov played it once and he won and
then everybody played it a million times
it's all it took and I've actually had
black of this position several times
although not in the last ten years but
between 1987 and 1998 I probably had
this position six or seven times with
black and there's at least 400
Grandmaster games okay and I think I nan
has had white and black in that position
again not at the same time okay now
instead of Bishop b4 black played the
other move which I think I played once
but maybe I didn't
c5 this is the other move and for some
reason I guess they know better than I
do
World Championship matches often feature
black trying to draw and white trying to
win and there's exceptions when Kasparov
and Fischer were playing World
Championship matches but nowadays if
you're black and you draw you're pretty
happy about it and they gets a really
boring position where basically only
white can win or it can be a draw but it
draws much more likely so Anand went for
that line okay so c5 e 4 is the point of
f3 and Bishop g6 was played although you
could also take on d4 and after taking
on f5 you can sacrifice a piece here by
just developing a piece for black again
when you're trying to draw you're you're
not going to do that so so I downplayed
Bishop to g6 and he's basically just
accepting that my bishops not so good
here because of this wall of pawns but
since I know theory to move 30 in every
game and they're all equal I'll do this
anyway okay and these kinds of openings
if you don't have new moves ready and
you could just repeat what happened
earlier from previous super Grandmaster
games and draw the way they did good way
to draw again for players of your level
and audience and those of you at home
you're not like trying to draw the game
you're trying to play good chess and win
at the world championship level if you
draw every game with black you're
probably going to win the match because
white does pretty well at the top level
so add on unlike the Anand of the 1980s
is going to play the most boring equal
way possible and then try to win with
white and the younger players generally
will mix it up with both colors but this
is the Anand of 2010 so that's a
different or not
okay Bishop III defending the d4 pawn
and we see a lot of trading a lot of
trading they say there's a lot of
treating because there's a lot of
treating now this may look funny to some
of you but if you go to the eye doctor
or we can we can take care of that then
it won't look funny any more often in
this variation especially in the slaw
because in the Slav with Bishop f5 the
bishops often on g6 one way to get your
Bishop out is to move your F pawn either
to f6 or f5 or sometimes both then the
bishop can get back into the game often
trading itself for this bishop and
you're not going to move your F pawn if
your Knights on f6 because that would be
cheating so it's very common for black
to play 9f g7 for this reason another
reason is black would like to play 96
because c6 is a good square for the
knight but in this case white could
trade knights and ruin black's pawn
structure so if we can get rid of the
knight on e5 then we could play knight
c6 attacking the bishop
so this Knight going to d7 actually
makes more sense than the other night
okay and everybody's taking everything
everybody's happy and rook c8 attacks
the bishop the commentator pointed out
that a6 is a common move defending the B
5 square c8 the bishop went to b5 a6 we
see a trade black has the two bishops
and this isn't a beginner class as we
had last hour but since most of you at
home were beginners we're going to talk
to you guys - normally when I'm playing
a beginner giving a lesson and at some
point of the game somebody loses the
right to castle like here they get very
upset they're like I can't castle well I
mean when you've traded all the pieces
off the board it's not necessary to
castle you're not going to get
checkmated when your opponent has no
pieces so if I was black I wouldn't want
my King on ga
because then I would move it to the
center later on the endgame so might as
well keep it in the center but white
does have a big advantage here in
compensation for what for blacks to
bishops the advantage is my bishop on d4
is gray and your bishops are terrible
and if you try to improve your bishop on
FA you're hanging your pawn on g7 and
you can't just have bad pieces the whole
game now again this is sort of for your
benefit for the players in question this
is their preparation for the game this
positions already occurred and they've
already analyzed it and anon concluded I
can draw this and then when I'm white
I'll play for a win and topple I've said
I could win this I'm better
and he played King e2 so his rook could
get into the game f6 now the bishop can
move because the G pawn is not attacked
and my bishop can get back into the game
rook to d1 threatening all kinds of
discovered Czechs and King to e8 okay
and this position had already been
played in other super Grandmaster games
which I'm sure both players know and
here Topalov played that move a 5 a 5
has never been played before until this
game and that was a prepared move from
him it stops the black pawns from moving
and maybe my knight can go to b6 later
maybe my rook could get active later
so a5 was part of his preparation for
the match and the annotator of the game
was surprised that an on had a really
big thing hear it he's like doesn't the
not know the move a5 ever been played
before and sometimes that does happen if
an engine has some normal book position
and it gives them blue that's never been
played and it says that that's the best
move sometimes both players know it
because they both use engines ok and
some players use engines during the game
but that would be illegal okay but
that's why we see so many draws at the
London chess classic nobody is using an
engine so they can't win okay so an on
played Bishop to East
getting his bishop out Bishop to b6 and
rook to f8 which is the best move and
there's several ideas one is to play f5
and the other is to play rook f7 then
move the bishop and the rook can come
into the center now again some of you
may want a castle here but that would be
illegal so you can't do it if I try to
castle the computer won't let me because
black already move just King twice some
of you probably want to play King f7 and
get your work out somehow but you can't
get your work out because my bishop is
there and king f7 would let the route go
to g7 so we can't play King f7 we can't
castle so now real keV fate actually
makes more sense
okay we're Casey won and now he played
f5 again when you have the two bishops
you generally want to open the position
up and this opens up the bishops
diagonal the rook has a little more
scope
put some pressure on e4 f5 makes a lot
of sense he five trying to keep it
blocked up and he played Bishop to g5
attacking the rook and if the rook moves
Bishop f4 would fork these two pawns so
he played Bishop e3 now a non made a
mistake and the annotator of the game
insinuates that an on didn't see his
opponent's next move I mean I could ask
him but see what time is in London now I
can't ask him but if it was you know if
it was earlier I could ask him he played
the move f4 and normally when you play
the move out for attacking the bishop
the guy moves his bishop away okay and
then if the bishop did move away this
would be quite a nice bishop now in my
previous lecture which was not recorded
there was a knight on c3 that couldn't
do anything and Karpov made some
brilliant maneuvers okay
well top walk did the same thing
but in a more tactical sense Topalov
played 94 he ignored his bishop because
he has well he has three threats
threatening rook takes for a check which
must be dealt with
threatening Knight d6 check and he's
threatening Knight takes bishop
so black doesn't have any time at all to
take definition
well obviously black has to play rook
takes rook otherwise I guess he resigns
because all those pieces are hanging
okay and now we play as missions ugh
Knight d6 check and luckily even though
it makes more sense to take with the
rook to get the open C file since our
bishop is hanging that doesn't make a
lot of sense but bishops could move
backwards so Bishop takes and because of
this little tactical trick topalov
played that's a pretty nice night it's a
car pop a lot longer to improve his
Knight then what topple of did okay
we're threatening the b-pawn so came to
c6 now I was a betting man and I would
never do that
just a second of the Vikings do you know
that's not good okay so if I was a
betting man I would say an on saw this
and saw his king went to c6 defending
the b-pawn and thought I have two
bishops I've traded rooks my king is
okay the annotator thinks he just didn't
see 94 to d6 it's hard to believe the
Kanaan plentiful championship would see
one move ahead okay
so white played Bishop to d2 he's
defending his a pawn he wants to play
rook c1 checked
Bishop to e7 check was played the
commentator is saying bishop before is
better but you know top olaf sees a
check Topalov plays check King retreats
to d7 if we go to d5 the rook
infiltrates on c7 and captures the
seventh rank so King g7 makes rook c7
look a bit silly Bishop to c3 and after
taking the knight again we have another
zhuge how many missions looks at one
game instead of taking back plays rook
to d1 and again he could take but he
plays H for stopping g5 and finally he
takes and we get to this position which
looks pretty drawn it's rook and Bishop
opposite bishops pawn structures that
basically the same the difference in the
positions is this f1 is pretty weak
that's why white played h4 to stop g5
and it's hard to imagine black taking
any of White's pawns without cheating
but it's very easy to see that I can
really gang up on this pawn now you have
been told your whole life lies ok mainly
by you know people you know and those
lies are this ship obviously colors is a
draw ok that's not true and even less
true is when there's rooks on the board
works and obviously colored bishops is
winning all the time I can show you many
examples vision of opposite colors is
more draw that are the same colors but
you know when you got pawns you can
Queen them ok so he played Bishop to d2
let's go take the F pawn and an on side
let's trade rooks and draw the game and
they got this position which is probably
a draw but winning chances for white why
has an extra pawn and White's King has a
lot of places to infiltrate and White
has a passed pawn in the 6th rank ok
again more likely a draw than a win but
as we saw today for you 2 weeks ago a
non Zen gameplay is a little suspicious
especially rook and pawn endings there's
another example of a non miss playing in
endgame ok so basically nothing happens
for quite a long time they're moving
around everybody's happy and in this
position
after nothing happening for a long time
yeah he plays the move Bishop to c6 this
is a very bad move and ends up losing
the game so often we want our Bishop to
be on this diagonal for two reasons we
want to be able to attack these pawns
and if the king is coming and taking
everything we want our Bishop to be able
to go to g3 and defend and Bishop c6 is
the worst you can't do any of that so
that was actually a blunder on his part
and after that he's actually losing the
game King age six and we need to play
King g8 h5 how do we defend our g6 pawn
we can't because the bishops on c6 so
okay played Bishop EA but he could have
played Bishop d3 otherwise and the
problem with the dish upon EA is we're
in zoogs Wang we can't move our King
away from our H pawn we can't move the
bishop away from the D pawn and we can't
move the bishop away from the jeep line
so black is really getting stuck four
moves here and if you hadn't played
Bishop c6 it would have been a draw
unfortunate now again I want to go back
and talk about something I talked about
last class players who are super GM's we
talk about them a lot we're like you
know that guy is good at the endgame
that guy's tall that guy is ugly that
guy doesn't smell good okay then let's
covers about all of them and topalov is
known for overpowering his opponents
playing lots of complicated theory he
plays the Padonia with black or used to
Benko gambit some really sharp openings
with lots of novelties and complicated
play and winning and Anand in the 80s
was known for the same thing and now
Anand is known for boring his opponent
to death and mainly drawing and so when
you see a game like this
like Oh Topalov Anand a really boring
end game that will be to an ons
advantage and BB you're right but those
are just technical typical things that's
not always the thing just because top
love is known for brilliant tactical
play doesn't mean he can't beat you
idiom was an end game he just doesn't do
that often probably the most famous
example and I've lectured on it before
and so of other people is the famous
sheer off move what's the most famous
move Sharov has played anyone even the
hey players oh no come on you're the
best player come on yeah you yeah yeah
see I knew he would know because the
best players always know yeah so Shirov
won a brilliant Bishop and pawn in game
by playing the move Bishop h3 giving up
his bishop so she Rob's best known move
was played in a Bishop and pawn endgame
okay not sacrificing a queen for me
although probably Petrosian a more
boring player his most famous is
sacrificing a queen for me there you go
the rich tapestry of life so the thing
is even though it's a long boring
endgame Topalov can still play well now
this position has something I'm very
interested in that I teach my students
someday one of them will listen and that
is King position I always tell my
students move your King up in the
endgame and they're like I'll get to it
later and then they resign because there
was no later and here there's no there's
no comparison White's King moving up the
board okay and drunken fashion and
blacks King moving backwards as much as
possible to defend so white is a pawn
ahead which is good and White's King is
much better than blacks which is also
good for white and because of these two
advantages white actually is winning and
a lot of times when I see an endgame
that has like drawing tendencies but one
side is a pawn ahead and somebody says
what do you think and I go White's upon
head that was easy
when your pawn had your pawn ad okay you
should win
and if you don't win that's because
there's some tricks like oh you would
win normally but not here I don't see
any tricks here I see a pawn on the
sixth rank that's close to queening and
I see a king that's a lot better than my
opponents King so I should be winning if
I'm a pawn up with a better King I have
a passed pawn on the sixth you can have
obviously bishops all day you can put
two more opposite bishops on the board
that might actually be a draw it should
put a black bishop here in a white
bishop here okay so even though opposite
vicious might have a tendency to be a
draw often that's with perfect play and
it's not just a draw and if two
supercomputers were playing and black
didn't play Bishop c6 earlier probably
the game would have been a draw but one
mistake and it's over because White has
a lot of advantages okay
so white played Bishop c5 and he said
it's your move make any move you'd like
well we can't move our Bishop to f7
because this Queens we can't move our
bishop this way because that G pawn is
hanging we can't play King f8 because of
g7 check so there's not a lot of moves
okay these pawns can't move because of
the opening novelty played by Topalov a5
now for those of you who are confused if
you play the move d5 there's the on
poisson rule we can take the pawn and in
fact he would have AZ that's that's
pretty good so blacks in a lot of
trouble you just can't move anything and
super grandmasters are very patient a
low-rated player would play b4 g4 take
on g6 make an illegal King move okay and
top pawns like you you can make a move
let's see where you go it's not like
black consumer improve his position just
bad stuff is going to happen okay so
finally he took the pawn in h5 because
he just can't move King when to g5 and
now if it was white to move white would
very easily win King goes d7 it's over
then I just win your Bishop so we can't
allow that
King g7 Bishop d4 check King to f7 and
now it's time if there's a blunder
that's pretty nice King takes pawn the
greedy move
what is that H pawn doing for black not
very much and now this gives black time
does black want his bishop to not be
able to move or does he want his King to
be in front of the pawn the Kings in
front of the pawn this bishop can attack
these pawns and defend this pawn if the
bishop is in front of the pawn my king
can attack it if your king is in front
of the pawn my King can attack it as we
discuss to dinner you can't move your
King next to somebody's King so we had
this discussion earlier today I don't
know what happened in the lecture so
when your king is in front of a passed
pawn and your opponent has a king and an
opposite colored bishop it can stay
there forever when your bishop is here
and the white king attacks that they
need to resign so King takes h5 is a
blunder because black has time for
Bishop b5 the bishop can defend the pawn
and the King can go to in front of the
pond and this would actually be a draw
okay but instead Topalov didn't allow
that he played Bishop to e5 and he said
it's your move the King on g5 is great
h4 was played hoping the King can
retreat so that we can get in there and
then king g6 trying to stop the King
from getting out now in this position
the problem that black has is White's
trying to come in and you guys are like
what problem is that
but the other problem is my king can go
this way attacking this pawn and king c7
and black has to stop both and on can
still stop both
kingi five and now he blunders with dish
of c6 this was actually the real blunder
not the previous bishop c6 and so now an
on didn't defend the best way but enough
to draw although not easy and that's
actually a big issue when you're
watching on the internet which that's
the only way I can watch London's on the
internet how can I do without the
internet what can I do Ben go to London
yeah when I'm watching one than on the
Internet everybody's like this is an
obvious draw and then they show you the
computer line so obviously if the
players you're cheating with computers
love even more drawings because they'll
play the obvious draw when they're
losing or worse now Bishop c6 is what he
played before and he ended up working
out okay for him but now he needs his
Bishop to defend this pawn and the King
to go in front of the pawn and instead
he played the blunder bishop c6 some
people incorrectly accuse super GM's of
being bad and game players and the
reason is they make mistakes in the
endgame so they're batting umpires one
of the reasons they make mistakes in the
endgame is the game's been going for
five hours so they're tired not because
they're bad hanging pliers first 20
moves of the game they've memorized most
of the moves and they haven't been
thinking anything yet so they played
pretty well then when you've been
thinking and thinking and thinking and
thinking and it's the year 2010 not 1988
then you're older than you used to be
and it's the fifth hour the sixth hour
now you tend to miss calculate so Anand
had really good reasons for blank Bishop
c6 he's stopping these pawns from moving
if this pawn moves the bishop takes the
pawn this pawn moves this ship takes
this pawn so it looks like a non just
not all his opponents pawns for moving
how could that be bad okay but actually
it's not true if he was right he'd be
right and what he should do is play
Bishop to d3 defending his H pawn and
then put his King on d7
yeah and this is the line that the guy
gives the GM who annotated the game and
he says this is a draw makes sense to me
looks like a draw yeah and now we don't
even need this pawn so let's take it off
still a draw
okay so Anand was drawing now there's
two possibilities he miscalculated or he
thought everything draws so I'll do
whatever I want
and he thought there's no way to break
through now one of my favorite games
that I've ever played and I've lectured
on here before probably more than once
is my game with the cuban grandmaster
who's now an american grandmaster goes
to webster anyone know nothing you very
good Fidel Carlos Jimenez and when I
play Corrales there were five or six
examples of overworked one piece was
doing several things and didn't work
that's the problem with Bishop to c6
we're stopping the puns for moving and
we're stopping this pawn from queening
but we can't do both although he try to
do both okay and it's especially
terrible for the player when you have
millions of people watching your game
normally when Richard pointer is playing
there's not a thousand grandmaster
saying oh we should have done the Hat
okay Richard plays game ends nobody
knows he's innocent when an ons playing
a World Championship everybody follows
the game live with their engines oh he
played a bad move what's wrong with him
okay well after six hours sometimes you
make a mistake and when you have your
engine going and it tells you it's a
mistake you're like what's wrong with
that guy well he doesn't have an engine
going so so now topalov played King aged
six the only move to defend h7 is King
to g8 let's say a tricks will go back
and roll the tape there's no there's no
tape either King g8
now you remember how white can't move
his pawns up well why can't move his
pawns up because if black takes this is
going to Queen so the bishops not good
at stopping everything
the bishop is good at defending h7 and
the King going to d7 that was the right
defensive setup now today although two
weeks ago for you
Anand resigned and people were baffled
the computers were in baffle they were
good resignation they said Anand was
like minus six so they liked that
resignation and hereafter G for Anand
once again fooling his public resigned
okay because a non realized what he had
done he can't take the pawn at f3
because this Queen's and now White has a
very simple winning method while black
has to defend his pawn on h7 he can't
let white play King takes h7
so black can't move anything is going to
go here and here and here and here and
White's going to play g5 and g6 and he's
going to take with the King and his
kings it'll walk in here so the
variation that was given by the
commentator was Bishop e8 Bishop g7
stopping the black King from going to f8
g6 king g6 and you can't stop me from
winning and the commentator went further
than I would have okay then
nothing the commentators stopped here
and now this pawn is going to promote or
why it's going to take everything and
top law is really good with two extra
Queens I've played on blitz chess I know
when he's got two extra Queens he's
pretty good okay did we get that joke
all right so like he'd be here both
chess
so after g4 much to his fans dismay he
resigned a lot of times on the Internet
when people are watching and they're not
cheating with their engines which is
really rare they just assume this was
agreed drawing the opposite colored
bishops nothing's happening they must
have agreed to a draw when the engine
says
like +7 and they're like whoa I guess he
resigned and there's another example of
this for those of you at home we want to
do some research if you look at the game
Magnus Carlsen was black against Takeru
Nakamura from the tall Memorial in 2011
which was the last round there was a
position where not only did not come or
resign the engines said that his
opponent was better but not winning so
people were really confused did they
agree to a draw did he resign in the
drop position but it turned out the
players were right not the engine there
was a very simple winning plan and as
you continue to play the plan the
computer says oh never mind it's winning
sorry ok and both players saw the
winning plan there was no defense to it
but if you look at that game and look at
the final position your engine will not
immediately tell you what's winning so
you will be confused this position
however your engine will tell you was
winning because it sees the idea of g6
king g6 King f6 and an on couldn't
believe what he did basically three
moves before the end he played this
terrible blunder he had to resign if he
had played Bishop d3 and King EA and
played properly would have drawn and
that was a world championship match you
can feel sorry for Anand but you'll have
the solace of knowing Anand won this
match by winning the last game which was
already we already made a video with a V
Friedman on game 12 and I wanted to make
a video but he wouldn't let me yeah game
12 was a great game but this was a nice
game too because the pressure was
building and building and building and
black was worrying about white
infiltrating with his King he was
worried about white queening is deep on
and the pressure he succumbed to it
because of so many hours of play and so
many variations calculated right at the
time when he was probably ok and
although people at home don't understand
it they're like my computer said it was
a draw why did he blunder well look at
your own games then you'll see why ok
your computer also tells it you
blundered to it when you could have
drawn and normally the top players
aren't blundering the first 20 or 30
moves of the game because therefore
- they're thinking well some prep they
have a lot of time on their clock but
when they're in time trouble and the
game is five hours old then we see
mistakes and well for those of you who
were here the same thing happened today
just when a Nam was pretty close to
drawing sort of like 50/50 he-man it was
a lost in one move and a rook and pawn
endgame and it's funny I was talking to
the commentators
and they were thinking yeah we're going
to be here another 90 minutes because
anons going to play d3 and who knows
what's going to happen and instead of
non play king d3 and they were there
another five minutes okay and this is
the same thing here you go from a drawn
position or a likely drawn position to
where the game ends in two minutes okay
it's very common at the lower level that
nothing is happening and then all of a
sudden blunder you resign happens in the
world championship match - just doesn't
happen as often and that's why when
we're looking for games to show you when
it goes draw draw draw draw draw draw
then we find a way we're like all right
let's look at this win and see what
happened it's actually more likely we
see a blunder a drawn position than some
guy getting crushed if you're getting
crushed while you played in the World
Championship should be getting crushed
but if you look at like Fischer Spassky
games those were great games
Karpov because far off games those were
great games and sometimes somebody
blundered and the game ended not like Oh
Fischer just play well in Spassky play
dad so he won that's not what happened
and that's not what happens in World
Championship matches we sometimes see a
blunder like Bishop c6 and the game just
ends in one move well I hope you enjoyed
that game I know I did and even though
Topalov enjoyed the game Anand enjoyed
the match because he retained his title
and the last game of the match if you
have a chance to look at it at home find
it on our video page top 11 on game 12
buy a V Friedman that was a great game
and well I guess it made up for this
game because it was the last game of the
match winning the last game of the match
much more important than the first game
alright see you guys next time